[Musique]
celle ci dès qu'on surnomme tête basse
dans le métier m
ba est aux bébés moi même j'ai
d'ailleurs le tournage tout en blue
jeans c'est vrai j'ai mis de la crème
dans la barbe des excuses en plus beaux
- sans rigoler c'est vrai mais je pense
ma non non non pas du tout parce que
c'est vrai et j'ai beaucoup de bons
retours sur toi et tu l'atteindre à
barbe
oui elle est bien taillée banal et bien
taillée gbagbo a parlé cette semaine à
celle où un peu déjà qu'il est
il n'aime pas son physique exactement ça
va prendre un dixième aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous tiendrez les 10 pour les sens
je sais pas par qui il a bien sûr on est
sur l'autoroute attention cyril un
matthieu delormeau n'est pas seulement
votre chroniqueur c'est aussi votre
locataire n'agirait voilà vous savez pas
et la semaine et c'est un bon plan pour
mathieu parce que il sait que si jamais
vous le virer il peut plus payer le
loyer
donc vous pouvez le garder en émission
je veux devenir votre locataire le plus
vite possible comme ça jusqu'en qu'il
avait peut-être justement ils se barrent
fin décembre on parle et où j'ai entendu
cela aurait il a donné son préavis ska
fin décembre il fallait pour l'état des
lieux c'est le 28 susucre là
[Rires]
la récupérer à coup sûr elle a fait un
truc là personnellement feront dossier
tous les trous et du marron repartent
fort boucher tous les trous fait
attention et c'est bon merci alors je
vais lui parenthèse way l'ampérage quand
électricien est venu il m'a dit
l'ampérage kia c'était pour un studio
bon ça quand je faisais une plaque est
une machine tout ce que je vous dis
c'est pas versailles
[Rires]
est ce que ce serait pas plutôt est ce
qu'il aurait pas racheter plus tôt cinq
studios pour vous dire bonjour à tous
c'est très rare quelqu'un qui regarde la
télé et qui met son micro non plus et
puis c'est pas besoin d'être tout seul
quand vous êtes dans la chambre vous
n'êtes pas besoin d'allumer le salon ah
oui il est habité bas bien pour les
lieux vient l'appartement la personne je
suis pas bien fait d'abord les gens là
ouais ouais ben alisme c'est la star du
8e cet appart
merci alors vous savez pas et donc je
demande d'appartements en commun la
semaine dernière tout se passait bien
quand soudain jean michel mr a fait une
vanne et syrie la prévôté de suspense et
votre tête de regrets voici la tête du
je vais te défoncer la race
[Musique]
alors commence à rentrer dans des avions
non non vous allez faire un état des
lieux avant après we may be n'a personne
d'autre à part
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus parce qu'on a tellement ça calmez
vous je sais que cette boue comme ça où
furent ces gentils non mais c'est vrai
on pense par hbo merci dit je trouve
très pur c'est vrai oui c'est dingue
c'est comme un fruit on voit comme ça il
est pur et quand on m'ouvre il est
pourri finalement alors série le sait
que le grand regret votre carrière ce
n'est pas d'avoir et ça ne cède que vous
n'avez pas été un grand créateur de mode
bref c'est un grand regret pour vous la
preuve vous critiquez tout le temps les
tenus debout chroniqueurs alors quand
vous recevez créateur olivier rousteing
votre confrère bien sûr vous libérer le
styliste qui sommeille en vous
le problème c'est que quand vous libérer
le styliste en vous massacrer tout le
monde voici cyril hanouna animateur
d'une nouvelle émission touche pas à ma
mode
[Musique]
céline quand on parle de mode il ya plus
de barcak existe faut pas vous
remplaciez cristina cordula dans les
règles du shopping parce qu'à mon avis
les candidates elle posté l'émission à
chialer leur mère était très mal a dit
tu vas changer à la paix mais alors si
vous voulez du catch up vous appelez
shimano toi payen les deschiens seuil à
eric naulleau bah tiens on a deux bons
d'un dock iphone
après avoir passé la soirée avec vous
olivier rousteing d'essayer de nous
transformer en égérie pour son nouveau
parfum
en exclusivité voici la publicité qui va
sortir demain en tunisie
[Musique]
ça me donne beaucoup mais je vais vous
dire tout cas je trouve c'est de mieux
en mieux à vie après tout c'est très
beau têtue vous ai offerts le blouson en
plus lequel de balmain vous avez offert
le blouson pour le dit ça ah bon tu le
sais parce que je ne sais comment vous
le savez mais parce que je suis tout
bébé à pato qui enseignait ma chatte
après toi qui renseigne toi oui toujours
pas donc voilà c'est quoi l'histoire
raconté aux téléspectateurs
bah je le sais et vous ai offerts le
blouson le lendemain vous le portiez
vous était très fier vous étiez en
balmain vrai ou faux je sais qu'olivier
vous aime beaucoup oui vous avez offert
le blouson et maintenant vous êtes
habillé en balmain alors vrai ou faux on
dit non c'est la vérité pas du tout il
m'a flatté mais en allemagne on va
prêter de mousson oui les rangs du non
j'ai prêté à lille m'a prêté un blouson
oui bah oui bien très bien
la somme amassée par une fois je vais je
voudrais une fois une chose que je vais
bien travailler tout le temps
sébastien peut que se régaler bourgoin
m'a demandé à bout de voix c'est un
crime non pas du tout monsieur l
emballement non pas du tout il va pas
dire blouson oui oui il est bien content
olivier rousteing tous les créateurs se
battent 1er série d'hbo
non non en tout cas vous êtes tous très
beau et très bien habillée par n'y a pas
un basset nom va faire le après l'aval
des sondages surtout parler gentiment et
ont misé sur l'originalité bator oui
frérot mais là c'est quoi mais qui fait
parler d'elle on dira marchand de glaces
à la foire du trône non mais c'est la
tendance les emplacements comme ça sur
les vrais quand jean mais là c'est moyen
passé dégueuler merci vous en tout cas
il ya quelqu'un qui appelle aimerait
bien récupérer le siège de sa twingo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya d'autres choses que ce soir je
voudrais rétablir la justice alors même
mon amie isabelle morini bosc est
souvent moquée par ce qu'elle aime
raconter plusieurs fois les mêmes
anecdotes depuis des années alors c'est
vrai que déjà se sont pas d'histoires
extraordinaires donc les entendre chaque
année les mêmes c'est compliqué et
matthieu delormeau avec sa gentillesse
habituelle où il fait souvent marqués
rappelez-vous de l'anecdote avait parlé
de taylor justement de salle annexe du
mariage et d'alain souvenez vous allez
voir après vous allez tout comprendre
mais c'est lui qui leur a fait
c'est un concert de jane et six salles
dont je désirais désillusion panier pour
lui faire plaisir
il lui a posé la question comme y avait
des bruits qu'elle est sourde fera
chaque saison vous allez voir moi moi
perso nous devons la spa voilà vous
allez voir parce qu'en fait il a donné
lors de l'heure de la revanche isabelle
a sonné pour vous parce que mathieu est
ce que vous considérez qu'isabelle
radote ou pas blague accord et bien
sachez vous radotez beaucoup plus qu
isabelle beaucoup plus en seulement huit
mois
on a eu droit à trois fois à la même
anecdote celles qui concernent le mal de
loi plus connu sous le nom du jard vous
allez voir il ya deux choses magnifiques
cet extrait on exactement la même chose
encore et encore personne même blague
personne à personne n'écoute personne
je vois tout le monde à les élever
[Rires]
j'aime bien les mêmes blagues la même à
chaque fois la même histoire la même
barça dans l'ouest avec nouveau chéri
pour le moment on revient sur mathieu de
langues qui disaient à isabelle
morini-bosc elle radoter mais cédric qui
est très fort et oui là il a trouvé
louis gérer j'étais derrière un sommeil
d'amour raconte j'ai d'ailleurs demandé
pour la cognée j'entends une anecdote
qui me semblait bien familière ouais je
me suis fait plusieurs fois qui la
raconte en fait il avait dû raconter
deux fois ci vous dire qu'en huit mois
matthieu delormeau a répété trois fois
la même anecdote et je rappelle que vous
vous avez fait trop fort je trouve cela
magnifique regardez c'est la revend
d'isabelle découvrir mathieu maurier
niveau 6 à 7 pour toi chérie qui ne
s'est pas attaqué pas un animal alors
démarrer vous un jour une fois je n'ai
jamais simple avec moi je me suis fait
mordre une coupe a passé une couille
parent jarre j'avais une énorme
hémorragie de la testicules droite parce
que j'avais été mordu par un jarre que
le début d'accord
mais il jure que ça tout seul marie de
loi c'est marie do we just son mari
était très en vue le mari de loi ah je
croyais en lui à l'âge des petits et il
m'a pincé la couille conaway ça fait un
mal de chien ça fait un mal de malades
nord et ça continue de la mer en panique
m'emmener aux urgences la mère m'a
emmené aux urgences et pendant 4 heures
j'ai une couille bleu parce qu'en fait
j'ai tout annulé
il a regardé ça et j'avais une
testicules qui avait doublé de volume et
café tout bleu je rassure tout le monde
et de marche très bien
joan taris vannes
c'est génial génial bravo c'est vrai
aussi que je raconte est vrai nom mais
ba et ba elle aussi tout est vrai mais c
est magnifique
isabella où il vous a bien mangé ça
c'est à dire eh bien à ce moment là vous
êtes heureuse telle ou telle un bravo
c'est la nasa nous a fait tous les mois
et moi le gros lourd qui sort à chaque
fois c'est bien mais faire c'est vous
c'est à dire que vous deviez ne sait
jamais ce que vous dites est pas du tout
mais pas du tout bas du cul bah oui
c'est ça oui bah oui c'est vrai tu me
coûte plus non ce n'est pas vrai enfin
t'inquiète pas tu vas l'écouté toi sur
l'état des lieux on était comme
d'habitude compter les prises de parole
de chacun qui parle peu qui parlent trop
c'est le nouveau classement n'oubliez
pas de prendre la parole qui partira pas
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans n'oubliez pas
de prendre la parole
non je ne dirais pas car c'est le
classement sponsorisé par ce qu spéciale
cette semaine en dernière position il a
perdu beaucoup de kilos de aussi la
parole géraud intervention pour benjamin
castaldi progresser ça c'est parce qu'on
est à la deuxième place on retrouve avec
23 interventions celui qui a plus pour
et servane concours d'histoire rémois
il s'est fait chine et est il arrivé à
lisa quand elle a croisé on passe haut
du classement il perd sa première
position gironde cette prise de parole
ont trois missions pour jean michel
maire et sa grande passion isabelle
morini-bosc n'est pas que j'ai pété au
première étage je me réveille le matin à
joux et de voix devant moi un mec tant
que match était tout nu lui vont prendre
la tête du classement 2 n'oubliez pas de
prendre la parole cette émission
aujourd'hui ça va partir à tout moment
en deux émissions il a pompé autant
qu'il a parlé 58 à man show pour le
fighter du paf
[Applaudissements]
la semaine prochaine les chérit le
calvez fini ses travaux bébé ici est
numéro 1 un amour et les images ont été
envoyés à mon avocat j'avais que je
travaille comme un fou chaque semaine
pour le cem six d'obtenir la note de 10
sur 10 sur l'échelle de l'adar cas
j'essaye j'ai désormais d'essayer
d'analyser en détail des évènements
dramatiques qui se passe sur ce plateau
vous allez voir les quelques jours vous
avez insulté publiquement sur son
plateau par l'animateur justement de ouf
non mais beaucoup sur lui aujourd'hui ah
oui pire dans tout ça ce sont les
réactions de vos employés vous allez
voir heureusement parmi tous ces
traîtres une personne n'a pas lâché et
ne vous lâchera jamais c'est le
lancement de la banalise le cd15 je
pleure et c'est très mignon derrière
l'image un peu de 2,2
et comme kelly fabien sont admiratifs on
sent qu'ils auraient aimé vous insultez
cyril hanouna l'invité lui se dit qu'il
n'avait jamais vu un patron se faire
traiter de connard en direct par exemple
n'a jamais eu passe-partout traité
olivier minne de connard ça se voit pas
benjamin castaldi jubile y rigole comme
quand il peut en des cyclades story ne
sait en faire croire que c'était un truc
de ouf alors qu'il savait que des
secrets étaient tous pourris et puis
valérie benaïm qui rit comme quand moi
je regarde c'est que de la télé que le
thème et camp installé ses décorations
de noël
tout le monde rit à tout le monde rit
tout le monde rit sauf un le fidèle
parmi les fidèles
celui qui ne comprends absolument pas
pourquoi les gens rient de meilleur
patron du monde
ce fidèle c'est jean michel mr la
loyauté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
c'est mon préféré le sait et le sexe est
mon préféré
voilà j'ai toujours dit je n'ai jamais
caché ses voilà c'est mon préféré le csa
mais c'est mathieu il est le premier
dans mon coeur je sais pas au niveau des
jambes sait dans quoi oui sécurité ou
sur michel il le sait ces cartes et
mathieu may et non mais jean-michel
c'est celui qui avec moi depuis le début
c'est le seul qui a fait la première
émission avec moi c'est à dire un podium
les trois premiers non mais ça y est on
sait que c'est normal c'est fidélité
c'est celui qui avec moi depuis le début
voilà c'est normal je suis votre
préférée mais c'est plus fidèles alors
pas du tout et puis c'est surtout le
plus court les gibelins coûté sais pas
quelle est votre histoire est ce que
vous avez vous calmez vous je l'aimé
bien quand même passé c'est sale et se
bat tous et pas du tout bien pas du tout
ça c'est pas assez qu'on est comme ça
jean michel et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs jean michel et moi on
finira l'émission ensemble c'est sûr et
certain et peut-être même parce qu'il ya
un ensemble dans la vie des jeunes s'est
pas imposé à d'ailleurs ces fois-là
ouais ouais vous êtes en train de louper
le coche à l'est le grand moment est
venu série ça fait 21 une fois que vous
êtes élu tabac de la semaine avec à peu
près autant de concurrence que le psg en
champion de france le tabac je le
rappelle c'est celui qu'elle plus tacler
ses collègues dans l'émission musique de
suspense
en coulisse série l'on m'avait confié
vous aviez tenté de vous adoucir cette
semaine pour laisser gagner quelqu'un
d'autre
par générosité parce que vous n'êtes que
générosité c'est ce que vous pensez
avoir réussi à vous contenir cette
semaine non non c'est pourtant j'aime
beaucoup cette franchise cependant et
bien écoutez le 22e tabac de l'histoire
de tpm paix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine cette semaine je vais me
faire venir j'ai repoussé les limites
j'aurais pu faire abattre tous les jours
ouais mais bon une fois par semaine et
je pense ça suffit est ce que vous
voulez voir le fruit d'un travail
combien le début ça commence à l'heure
de masse singer et d'audace
mais pour l'instant hier à ben voilà il
y avait donc isabelle sur l'a1 bernard
montiel vous avez fait de vous vous avez
fait un bac ps montbrun soleil tout à
tour si vous avez le mode de réponse
vous rester en course
sinon c'est l'élimination et bien sûr
ceux qui sont éliminés sur illuminé pour
le restant de l'année et vous n'y verrez
ce qu'on appelle une heure à d'accord et
rap qu'est ce que c'est rachid arhab
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut montrer votre
progéniture
mais évidemment je pense est au beau
fixe
[Applaudissements]
dans son rôle pour moi le meilleur
c'était maxime dans son rôle dans son
bureau il est génial j'adore génial je
réussisse